It's always heartbreaking to discover that
the actors who’ve played your favorite characters
have passed away.
Adding to our first list that you can find
on our YouTube channel, these actors have
also moved on without much public fanfare.
It doesn't matter whether these actors were
Hollywood royalty—they helped portray characters
we'll never forget.
Richard Bonehill
While you might not recognize Richard Bonehill's
face, you'll recognize some of the characters
he's played over the years...especially if
you're a Star Wars fan.
Bonehill's history as a competitive fencer
and swordsmanship coach landed him work on
Highlander, Flash Gordon, and Doctor Who.
He also played a variety of characters in
The Empire Strikes Back and Return of the
Jedi.
For the most part, he filled various background
roles, including multiple Stormtroopers and
Rebel Alliance soldiers.
You'd probably best recognize him as Nien
Nunb, Lando Calrissian's alien co-pilot during
the attack on the second Death Star.
Bonehill passed away on February 4th, 2015
at the age of 67.
Earl Hindman
Earl Hindman had a relatively low-profile
show business career, appearing in movies
like Silverado, and The Taking of Pelham One
Two Three.
Throughout the '70s and '80s, he starred as
Bob Reid in more than 450 episodes of Ryan's
Hope.
Most '90s kids will remember him as Wilson,
the mysterious-but-friendly neighbor of the
Taylors on the hit sitcom Home Improvement.
Hindman died on December 29, 2003 at the age
of 61 due to lung cancer.
Bernie Mac
One of the original Kings of Comedy, Bernie
Mac built his career with a stand-up routine
heavily influenced by Richard Pryor.
Many might recognize Mac as Ice Cube's neighbor,
Pastor Clever, in Friday.
Mac went on to star in Charlie's Angels: Full
Throttle, Ocean's Eleven, and Transformers
before headlining his own sitcom, The Bernie
Mac Show.
During the last years of his life, Mac suffered
from Sarcoidosis, which heavily affected his
lungs.
He succumbed to pneumonia complications in
August 2008 at the age of 50.
Richard Attenborough
Long before he founded an ill-fated amusement
park using the secrets of dino DNA, Richard
Attenborough was already an accomplished and
award-winning actor.
Attenborough starred alongside Steve McQueen
in The Great Escape.
He also won two consecutive Golden Globe Awards
in 1967 and 1968 for his work in The Sand
Pebbles and Doctor Dolittle.
Younger filmgoers will never forget Attenborough
as John Hammond, whose ambitions led to the
creation of Jurassic Park.
But that's just one short chapter in a life
that ended in August of 2014 at the age of
90, after many great cinematic achievements,
on both sides of the camera.
Sage Stallone
Rocky 5 is arguably the least loved film of
the iconic boxing series.
But under its cheesier elements, there's still
a solid story about the champ going broke,
losing his ability to box, and nearly losing
his relationship with his son.
Sylvester Stallone brought his own 14-year-old
son, Sage, to play the part of Rocky Jr. in
the film.
After college, Sage continued working in small,
low-key film projects.
Unfortunately, Sage died in 2012 at the young
age of 36 due to a heart attack brought on
by coronary artery disease.
Chris Penn
The younger brother of veteran actor Sean
Penn, Chris Penn followed in his sibling's
footsteps, breaking into Hollywood at the
tender age of 12.
Penn is best remembered for his portrayal
of mob scion Nice Guy Eddie in Reservoir Dogs.
He also appeared in Footloose, Rush Hour,
Kiss Kiss Bang Bang, and Grand Theft Auto:
San Andreas.
He died on January 24, 2006 at the age of
40 due to cardiomyopathy, with morphine, valium,
marijuana, and codeine all found in his body.
Sean Penn attributes Chris' death to the weight
he visibly gained during the '90s.
Richard Griffiths
A veteran stage, film, and television actor,
Richard Griffiths is known most for his portrayal
of Harry Potter's awful uncle, Vernon Dursley.
Outside of the Harry Potter series, Griffiths
won a slew of awards for his portrayal of
English teacher Douglas Hector in a play called
The History Boys.
He also starred in a variety of projects,
including Superman 2, Gandhi, Sleepy Hollow,
King Ralph, and The Hitchhiker's Guide to
the Galaxy.
Griffiths passed away at 65 on March 28, 2013
due to complications shortly after having
heart surgery.
James Avery
Whether you call him the Big Guy or Uncle
Phil, James Avery became a household name
through his portrayal of Philip Banks on The
Fresh Prince of Bel-Air.
The burly actor had plenty of small roles
throughout his TV career, but was also known
for his voice acting work.
He was the voice of War Machine on Iron Man
and Shredder on Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles:
"Well what is it?"
Avery also did voices for The Prince of Egypt,
The Real Ghostbusters, Fist of the North Star,
and Hulk Hogan's Rock 'n' Wrestling.
Like Richard Griffiths, Avery died from complications
following heart surgery in 2013 at the age
of 68.
Thank you for always being a stern, funny,
and loving father figure on TV, Uncle Phil.
Lou Albano and Danny Wells
"Captain" Lou Albano and Danny Wells entertained
millions of children from 1989-1991 on The
Super Mario Bros. Super Show.
The program featured Nintendo cartoons, bookended
by Albano and Wells playing the two beloved
plumber brothers during live-action sequences
at their Brooklyn residence.
Albano and Wells also voiced the animated
versions of Mario and Luigi during the Super
Show cartoons.
Captain Lou was a WWE Hall of Fame member
with a prominent professional wrestling career
that started in 1953 and ended in 1995.
Albano died on October 14, 2009 from a heart
attack at the age of 76.
He left behind a wrestling legacy that includes
one of his grand-nephews, former MMA/UFC fighter
and professional wrestler Phil Baroni.
Danny Wells, who played Luigi, was known for
his TV guest appearances on the likes of The
Jeffersons, Happy Days, Punky Brewster, Chips,
and The A-Team.
He also did voice acting for Heathcliff, Batman:
The Animated Series, and more.
He died of undisclosed causes on November
28, 2013.
Richard Harris
Yet another major loss to the cast of the
Harry Potter series, Richard Harris played
Albus Dumbledore in The Sorcerer's Stone and
The Chamber of Secrets.
Outside of Hogwarts, Harris was also an accomplished
singer, actor, director, writer, producer,
and songwriter.
Harris won Grammy and Golden Globe awards
for his work on 15 different albums and more
than 70 films, including Camelot, The Guns
of Navarone, Gulliver's Travels, Patriot Games,
Unforgiven, Gladiator, and The Count of Monte
Cristo.
After being diagnosed with Hodgkin's disease,
Harris died on October 25, 2002 at the age
of 72.
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know which
actors you want the world to remember...